يقرع جرس المدرسه هنا رغم انه يوم السبت
يروي الطلاب الى صفوفهم في اليوم الاول من
عطله الاسبوع في برلين الصفوف هنا ليست
اجباريه فالمدرسه هي مدرسه لتعليم اللغه
العربيه
الى
مملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الى المانيا ياتون الى هنا مره في الاسبوع
لتعلم القراءه والكتابه
العربيه لازم اعرف احكي واكتب بالعربي
لغه الدين عندي لانه عربي لازم اعرف
اقرا قران منيح عشان هيك لازم اعرف اقرا
لغه القران لغه الام وبحب احكي عربي
التي تعلموا العربيه هنا ايضا يقولون
بانهم يريدون لاولادهم ان يحافظوا على
لغتهم ولا ينسونها الاء المولوده في دمشق
وصلت الى المانيا قبل خمس سنوات وتعلم
ابنتيها العربيه في هذه المدرسه
يمكن لانه انا عم بزرع فيهم محبه اللغه
العربيه ومن خلال التواصل دائما اقرباء
بالعكس بتستمتعه يعني وثلاثه ارباع وقتهم
بالمدارس الالمانيه بتخاف مثل اي
امنوا اللغه العربيه يدرسون
ثلاثي حصص مختلفه يوم السبت والاحد
90% من الطلبه العرب من القادمين الجدد
اهاليتهم يرغبون بالتدريس ابنائهم اللغه
العربيه للمحافظه على ثقافتهم وجذورهم
وايضا اا للسهوله التواصل مع اولياء
امورهم في اقربائهم تنتهي الصفوف ويغادر
الطلاب ومعهم بضعه كلمات اضافيه كل اسبوع
يامل وداويهم ان تبقى معهم حتى يقدروا
لتذكرهم بجذورهم وثقافتهم
العربيه بنين